the light emitted by high intensity
discharge car headlights are very
effective in activating the reflective
paints of road markers thereby making
driving at night safer and maybe we have
no error so let's just think about this
a little bit what's the subject here
well the subject here is the light
emitted by high intensity discharge car
headlights now is this a singular
subject or a plural subject
well it's we're really just talking
about the light we're talking about the
light and then they tell us what type of
light the light emitted by high
intensity discharge car headlights so
the light is clearly is clearly singular
when you read the entire the entire
subject you might get a little confused
because it ends when you're talking
about emitted by high intensity
discharge car headlights and you see
that headlights your brain might be
thinking oh maybe this is plural but
remember we're really talking about the
light and this whole part this whole
part that i'm underlying in green is
just really just describing the the
light that we're talking about so the
subject is really a singular subject so
the verb that goes with it also needs to
be singular
but if we look at underlying part a
right over here r is not the singular
version of is it's the plural version so
this right over here is plural it should
be singular and to really test why this
sounds strange or why this why this
doesn't make sense is ignore this green
part right over here and just test it
out that way if i just said the light
are very effective that makes no sense
that doesn't that i have a singular verb
with a singular subject with a plural
verb so this has to be a singular verb
it has to match the subject this is much
better the light is singular subject
singular verb the light is very
effective so the error is in part a this
r should be
an is